[Music]
do you know that a large caramel popcorn
at the movies can wreck up to 1800
calories that's almost your entire
calorie allowance in a day and most of
the time we tend to have it with soft
drinks so you just snack away and step
away that's a killer to your waistline
and also all the athletes you have put
into the gym but here's the good news
popcorn can be a great a low calorie
snack option one cup of plain air pop
popcorn
only has 31 calories and you can choose
to flavor it how you like it
popcorn is a whole grain which means
it's a great source of dietary fiber it
is also fat-free sugar-free and
gluten-free so it is definitely a much
healthier option in comparison to nachos
pretzels or chips which tends to be high
in sodium
it is really simple to make stovetop
popcorn but follow these steps carefully
trust me you'll get really excited
making it add two tablespoons of oil
into a large and deep pot I used coconut
oil then turn the heat up to high and
add two to three kernels of popcorn
cover the pot and wait for those kernels
to pop once they have popped the oil is
hot enough add in half a cup of popcorn
kernels cover and give it a swirl to
coat the kernels evenly in hot oil you
start to hear the popcorn popping slowly
at first then crazy-fast it's really
exciting
give the pot a good shake every now and
then to avoid the popcorn from burning
once the popping has slowed down to
nearly a stop turn of the heat wait for
a few extra seconds for the last few
pops remove the lid and allow the
popcorn to cool down this makes about 12
cups of popcorn here's the fun part
we're going to flavor our popcorn six
ways each recipe makes eight cups of
popcorn first salted chocolate popcorn
add a pinch of salt and drizzle with 50
grams of melted dark chocolate mix until
well coated each cup only has about 87
calories peanut butter popcorn add a
pinch of salt 2 tablespoons of maple
syrup and quarter cup of peanut butter
again mix until well coated each cup has
about 115 calories for an Asian twist
try this sesame seaweed popcorn add 1
tablespoon of toasted sesame oil 2
tablespoons of sesame seeds and two
sheets of crumbled nori seaweed mix it
up each cup has about 85 calories
let's make match our green tea popcorn
add a pinch of salt and 1 tablespoon of
matcha powder mixture mix it up each cup
has about 70 calories and you're
beginning all the benefits from matcha
if you like a spices then make this next
recipe coconut curry popcorn add one
tablespoon of curry powder and about
quarter cup of desiccated coconut keep
mixing each cup has about 71 calories
and finally my favorite granola popcorn
add half a cup of homemade granola a
pinch of salt 1/2 a tbsp of garlic
powder 1/2 a tablespoon of smoked
paprika 1 tablespoon of coconut oil and
2 tablespoons of maple syrup combine all
the ingredients this makes a really
great high energy snack and each cup has
about 117 calories popcorn can be a
healthy snack option so make your own
these are just a few of my favorite
flavors you can play by your popcaan how
you like it so experiment with different
flavors and let me know which is your
favorite in the comments below don't
forget to tag me at Joanna's official
and hashtag chaser recipes be sure to
like this video share this recipe on and
subscribe to my youtube channel for a
lot more healthy recipes and also
workout videos guys don't forget to turn
on your notification button so that you
will get notified every
I share a new video all the best and
enjoy your healthy low snack